mais bon
on va voir où on peut vous situez est ce
que comme françois mitterrand vous avez
des enfants illégitimes
moi non pas à ma connaissance non est ce
que comme lionel jospin vous avez déjà
tiré sur un joint
non est ce que comme françois bayrou
vous avez déjà giflé un gamin lors d'une
visite en banlieue
non mais ça arrive dans ma commune dont
c'est arrivé dans ma commune comme maire
de balancer une aux deux calottes et des
petits cons qui m'a arraché en plus les
fleurs fraîchement plantés dans les
massifs de fleurs de la commune payés
par les contribuables
bon disons plus de barre de fer devant
le père est venu me voir en disant vous
avez frappé mon fils j'ai dit oui et je
regrette pas il m'a dit mais je pourrais
porter plainte j'ai des maux aussi vous
savez qu'ils m'ont arraché pour 15000
francs
un mec a dit bon d'accord
on voit qu'on peut pas vraiment pas est
ce que comme valéry giscard d'estaing
vous comptez un jour écrire un livre
érotique pourvoi je crois pas je joue
papa je crois pas parce que j'ai entendu
françois mitterrand de se moquer
tellement du président giscard d'estaing
pour cette écriture là que j'ai pas
envie que par delà la tombée avec les
forces de l'esprit dans le coup il fait
de moi est ce que comme nicolas sarkozy
vous êtes ami avec christian clavier
je connais pas christian clavier est ce
que comme edouard balladur faisait déjà
dansé sur une table ou chat dû m'arriver
un jour où j'étais bourré quand j'étais
très jeune comme tout le monde
il a même déposé une gerbe
est ce que comme des ministres ce cadre
vous ne savez pas vous servir d'un
magnétoscope
je suis pas très habile dans ce genre de
choses effectivement
est ce que comme non pas que strauss
kahn ce sens et que strauss kahn savait
tout oui je suis heureux d'être venu
l'arrêter mission pour apprendre qu'il
ya un truc qui sait pas
est-ce que comme laurent fabius vous
aimez bien les carottes et la star
academy au star academy je regarde pas
parce que malheureusement j'ai pas
beaucoup le temps de regarder la
télévision les carottes oui parce que
comme bernard kouchner lorsque vous
regardez un match de l'équipe de france
de football
vous comptez les noirs je regarde jamais
de match
ce que ça me casse les pieds est ce que
comme chirac vous avez déjà promis de
vous baigner dans la seine
sûrement page sait pas nager gérant de
l'eau est ce que comme alain juppé on
vous a déjà reproché des emplois fictifs
a jamais jamais jamais j'ai toujours les
gens que j'ai employé ont toujours été
employée régulièrement est ce que comme
bertrand delanoë vous êtes déjà fait
poignarder non je suis menacé de mort
d'une façon régulière depuis 1908 1982
on m'a tiré dessus une fois chez moi
entre un soir ma femme a été menacé son
fils a été menacée mais pour le moment
on n'a pu éviter les balles quoi vous
êtes toujours vos gardes du corps avec
vous là bas je suis protégé de temps en
temps quand ils le font c'est pas
tellement envie de donner l'occasion à
des salopards de faire un carton sur moi
d'accord mais c'est pas que je crains la
mort je crois pas en dieu je m'en fous
mais j'ai pas envie de ça parce que je
trouve ça leur ferait trop plaisir mais
pourquoi
sérieusement pourquoi vous êtes menacés
de mort et pourquoi vous êtes toujours
c'est quelque part chez koei g2g de
vieille histoire qui date de l'époque du
pouvoir
j'ai les trafiquants de drogue qui
m'aiment pas beaucoup parce que quand
j'étais minot des douanes je leur ai
fait brute de l'isère
les corses me déteste et je leur rends
bien que je parle des nationalistes
naturellement j'ai agi contre d'une
façon assez rigoureuse est bon il ya un
certain nombre de gens qui ont envie je
me suis occupé d'affaires du
moyen-orient aux affaires libanaises en
82 83 dans des missions du fichier bref
je peux vraiment envie de donner
l'occasion donc on passe à cartons mais
en tout cas s'il devait y avoir des
échanges du coup j'aimerais bien ne pas
être le seul à tomber un fait qui
préfèrent la grippe aviaire mais là
c'est deux balles dans la tête
françois mitterrand